and as we mentioned at the top we're
very happy now to have vice president
mike pence with us
you know you have to follow hannity mr
vice president so that's just the way it
works
good to be with you laura it's so great
to see you tonight for a live interview
and it's late i understand you've got a
very long day
you you see this narrative taking hold
though you have cases
uh rising across the country this is the
media's narrative
schools are waffling on opening
governors are pulling back on some of
their reopenings especially in blue
states
and the american people are giving the
administration
mixed marks on the handling of the of
the virus
even though the handling of the virus
has been so much better in so many ways
in red state america that it has been in
blue state america so what do you have
to do to convince voters
especially in middle middle america that
you're doing this
right mr vice president well look i i
think the american people
have seen this president take decisive
action from very early
in the coronavirus pandemic i mean laura
before there was a single case of
community transmission
before the end of january president
trump
suspended all travel from china stood up
the white house coronavirus task force
and in the first few weeks of february
we actually began the process of
developing
a vaccine and you just heard a week ago
that we're already
at a historic pace in phase 3 clinical
trials of the first coronavirus vaccine
for this country could well be available
for this fall in the midst of all of
that
we've taken testing from a standing
start to nearly
60 million coronavirus tests performed
ppe is in great abundance even across
the areas of the country where we've
seen
rising cases and working closely with
governors as the president and i have
from the very beginning
not only did we confront the dramatic
rise in cases the
the crisis that emerged in new york and
new jersey connecticut
then detroit new orleans but the good
news as the president said today is
we're already beginning to see across
the sun belt
not only a stabilization of cases but
cases
are declining emergency room visits are
declining
and we're going to work closely with
states all across the heartland i think
at the end of the day the american
people know
this president has spared no expense
he's marshaled
not only a whole of government response
to the coronavirus pandemic
but a whole of america response and uh
and it's all just
evidence of the kind of leadership that
president trump has brought for this
country
over the last three and a half years and
and i'm ready to take the
story of this pandemic but also the
story of the way this economy
is already recovering on the foundation
president
trump poured in the first three years
we've already put seven
million americans back to work and i
want to get to the months of a recovery
yeah i want to get to that open up our
schools i want to get to that in a
second but
states like florida and texas
are still doing much better on covid
than new york
i mean that's just look at the numbers
per million like what is that factor of
five or six but earlier today governor
cuomo
had the gall to say this about the trump
administration's handling of the virus
watch we do need to reset but the reset
has to start
at the top uh we have confusion we have
chaos we don't have operations set up
and i think it has to start with the
president of the united states i think
he has to stand up and say what he
didn't say
six months ago he has to say to the
american people that covet is serious
the white house dr burks
the secretary they're sending the exact
wrong message
they've learned nothing in six months
you've learned nothing in six months
your response to governor cuomo 32 000
dead in new york
well our hearts grieve uh for the the
fact that uh
one in five of all the american lives
have been lost
in the coronavirus pandemic were lost in
the state of new york and some of that
was because of poor decisions by the
state and by governor cuomo but look
i liked it better when he said that
president trump's leadership in the
pandemic was in his words
phenomenal he said that repeatedly as we
surged
testing as we search ppe as we sailed
in a hospital ship as we build hospitals
in new york
i i couldn't be more proud of the
of the support that we rendered to the
people of new york and i think the
people of new york know that health care
workers know that families know that
i know the governor phil murphy just
across the river
uh has continued to express his great
appreciation for president trump's
leadership
but i i have to tell you there'll be
there'll be plenty of time
uh in the future to to debate various
responses
our focus is entirely uh on dealing with
this pandemic
marshaling the full resources of the
government and uh
and but i think the american people know
the facts here
and and the fact that that governor
cuomo has been on again off again
he's complimented the administration's
response and then he pivots
to criticism i think people see through
that it's just
we're going to stay focused on the task
at hand and that is saving lives
protecting
the vulnerable and putting this
coronavirus in the past um mail-in
ballots sir
are a looming disaster we're seeing this
in new york
of course and i i foresee a scenario
where president trump could actually be
ahead
in key states on election night but
those states
couldn't have counted all the mail-in
ballots philadelphia detroit milwaukee
miami-dade you could
you could foresee a situation where this
would go on for weeks what can you
say to tonight to assure us that this
election
will not be stolen by democrat election
officials in swing states
well look the president made it very
clear whether it's the
power grab in nevada that the president
or the governor of nevada was signing
that allowed not only for
universal mail-in ballots but also
uh vote harvesting as it's called
we're headed to the courts look the the
right to vote the one person one vote
right
is at the very center of our democracy
and and the president's made it very
clear that we're going to not going to
stand
idly by while you see uh
you know democrats states and democrat
governors
use the backdrop of the coronavirus to
send
millions of ballots all across their
states and all across this country
let's be clear though laura absentee
balloting is
perfectly acceptable you have to apply
for an absentee ballot
signatures are checked it's confirmed it
has a long tradition
and we want to encourage any american
that is not able to go to the polling
place for any
reason to apply for an absentee ballot
today but this
universal mail-in voting where you're
going to see
literally ballots showered all across
the state
uh it's just it's it is right for fraud
and and we are headed straight uh to the
courts to put a stop to it
uh mr vice president we really
appreciate you're joining us tonight we
had a lot other
uh more questions but we'll have to come
have you come back real soon please
thank you so much thank you lord good to
be with you